to introduce anthem she has more than 10
years of international management
experience creating and leading
cross-functional team working with large
corporates and smes she has led the
introduction of new products and
services across 140 markets in her
current role as a consultant at the
pastra alliance she is a strategic theme
lead for improving the efficiency and
effectiveness of rnd her role includes
leading communities of interest in life
science and healthcare r d for more than
one three member companies including the
pistol alliance lab of the future
community she also leads the pastoral
alliance's new women's assembly
leadership pilot program and is
responsible for developing other good
non-competitive cross-industry
initiatives where members of the pistol
alliance can collaborate to solve common
challenges together
i joined the pistoia alliance as a
strategic finlet as you presented
earlier and in my current role i see
myself as a connector
i connect people i connect their ideas
for more than 200 member companies of
the vistoy alliance all across the r and
the ecosystem
i facilitate collaborations between
these companies in order to address and
to solve common challenges in a
non-competitive way
in this session i'm going to present two
of the currently running initiatives one
is called the lab of the future which is
a community of interest
and the other one is the women in stem
which is a program that we are currently
uh piloting
so uh uh before going into the
presentation i'd like to tell you a few
words about the pistol alliance for
those of you that maybe didn't have the
chance to work with this organization
it's a not-for-profit organization
uh it gathers under its umbrella more
than uh 200 member companies including
the 16 out of the 20 pharma companies
top 20 pharma companies and the mission
is to lower the barriers to innovation
in life science
and in health care and r d through
pre-competitive collaboration
this means that we bring at the same
table different companies that might be
competitors in the business environment
but we facilitate a collaboration
between them for a common purpose
the
changed our lives in many many ways
including in the way we work
more companies became more permissive to
remote working
and the cross industry collaborations
also increased we saw high acceleration
of digital transformations across the
healthcare industry
and the benefits of this
industry-wise collaborations are very
well known and
more and more organizations we see that
are leveraging a legal framework that
not-for-profit organizations can
facilitate in order to collaborate with
different organizations
research-based organizations maybe
digital technology players also page
patient groups for example
uh both of the examples that i'm going
to show you are global initiatives which
means that we involve people around the
world to support each other to share and
to learn and to address certain
challenges but also to look for
solutions together in the benefit of the
whole industry
and
when you will go on the pistol alliance
website you can see a list of projects
and the list of communities of interest
and i highlighted just some of them on
the right side of the screen
uh among all these initiatives we also
have the lab of the future community
which has a mission of driving a
pre-competitive approach to building the
next generation of laboratory
environment and we are looking from a
perspective of data standards processes
instruments and knowledge sharing
and the members of this community are
presenting use cases are sharing the
challenges and best practices but they
are also exploring different ideas
and initiate projects that can help
support the lab transformation in the
digitization
i want to show you how at the pistoia
alliance we create new projects we are
constantly developing
new projects uh and the process starts
with the ideation phase
uh where the pre-competitive project
idea is being raised the idea can come
from anybody
uh then the idea is being validated with
the community in terms of the benefits
and the interest
and once there is a buy in for that
particular idea it then starts to take a
shape into a project that has a clear
problem statement and the industry
benefit
the outcome can be a member-funded
project or a program it can be a new
formed community of
experts and um this is the exact same
path
that
we went on for creating the woman in
stem pilot program that i'm about to
present you so women account for only
three percent of the ceos in this field
and this is why the pistol alliance has
chosen to focus this pilot scheme on the
leadership roles because we believe that
um we believe in the top-down
changes and in creating more role models
for the future generations
um
and just to tell you that these women in
stem pilot program it's a first step in
a wider diversity and inclusion in stem
leadership initiative and we are aiming
to run a series of future programs as of
september this year
uh using the feedback and the learnings
from this pilot program um
we would like to form a community of
leaders who share the same values and
that want to contribute to the change in
the overall industry either by directly
changing or by promoting uh equality in
their organizations
[Music]